[Musique]
pensez vous que les québécois vont
tomber en amour avec votre pendu selon g
sa mère cuisine aujourd'hui le pont d'où
un plat typiquement congolais à base de
feuilles de manioc est ce que vous
cuisinez souvent ensemble oui c'est elle
qui fait toutes mes pots tout c'est là
que je veux qu'il prépare sa ket pense
que c'est ça l'enjeu qui fait tout et il
y a quelques mois selon ja lancer sa
propre gamme de produits sous
appellation african disponible dans son
épicerie située dans le quartier saint
henri à montréal nous ont blessés
spécialisée dans les prêts à manger
exotiques
donc c'est vraiment une épicerie fine
qu'on va retrouver les sauces africain
fait à manger on va y trouver de
confiture on va retrouver des repas puis
bien sûr on va retrouver tous les
ingrédients que les africains ils ont
besoin de faire leur est pas si vous
voulez pourquoi autres aussi peu de
produits africaine dans les grandes
épiceries parce que des produits
asiatiques des produits du moyen-orient
du liban et compagnie on en trouve
facilement je pense moi le
les grandes chaînes sont prêtes à voir
des produits africains n'y a pas assez
les joueurs assez serré pour aller
cogner devant les portes des grandes
chaînes à l'heure actuelle c'est
justement pourquoi moi je suis dans ce
domaine là parce que je comprends pas
pourquoi moi j'ai pas doit d'aller
chercher mon boulot chez iga ou chez
maxi par exemple les sauces sont à la
base de l'alimentation de nombreux pays
africains et des caraïbes et solange se
fait un devoir de les faire connaître
ici
enfin l'exemple on a les poings doux et
ensuite on à la sauce garda qui est pour
la checker jeu tu vas au sénégal il ya
l'association qui est très très très
populaire donc évidemment on à
l'association
et si tu vas un haïti par exemple à l
épi qui liste les familles pique nique
d'africaines que je suis je vais pas
jeter de la nourriture c'est
inconcevable pour moi
alors on transforme complètement tout
c'est comme ça et enée d'autres choses
entre autres les confitures probiotiques
le jus cambodia mais avec des saveurs
plus exotique est question de faire
connaître ses produits
l'entrepreneur s'est installé au marché
jean-talon l'été dernier le goûter ce
que c'était quelque chose vient alors
ici c'est tout est produit à fouquet b
quoi un peu méchant donc là un autre
mandat on essaie vraiment de faire
connaître la culture afro québécois à
travers la nourriture
ça c'est une constante des bananes
je compte
elle y va avec le cra et on a une bonne
partie des créateurs qui est africain
on a aussi beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
clients qui sont les autres communautés
c'est une première au retour de papaye
facile de faire déguster des confitures
de fruits mais ça prend un peu plus
d'audace pour goûter à la sauce aux
chenilles de solange mais le ccc pas
gagné cela de faire manger des chenilles
ou nord-américaine ont pas encore écouté
au marché jean talon on a mis le pesto
déchets ni ça attire beaucoup des gens
auxquels les gens y viennent sont
curieux
[Rires]
ça goûte comme les crevettes ou de
poisson quoi ton cgt vous pouvez la
chenille au fait nous les chenilles
cessez vos mains allemand qui est
reconnu comme même hogan
as tu vois ça c'est vraiment comment on
peut l'utiliser comme un peso bien pâte
également au 6 juillet avec une petite
portion vous avoue que ce matin je
pensais pas aller manger la chine et à
ses lois les mauvais de là vous dire que
je vais commencer à avoir été dessinée
chez nous je pense pas maintenant c'est
loin d'être mauvais ça goûte vraiment le
poisson fumé séché a défendu quand même
quelques années donc vous êtes une bonne
vendeuse vous avez votre épicerie pignon
sur tout mais l'objectif le rêve c'est
quoi les rêves ça serait vraiment où
justement l'heure de rentrer les petits
pots jusqu'aux grandes chaînes il est
consommé ces produits à travers le monde
une chance pour la suite des choses 9 rc
coc